[Inaudible].
Are the state Corona virus shutdowns taking away our personal freedoms.
Joining me to discuss that a more political commentator and author of don't burn
this book,
which Dave Rubin just told me has made the New York times bestsellers list.
Wait and go, Dave. All right. Listen to me. So yeah,
all of us as Americans are independent,
we're freedom loving and the locking us up. Okay. Whether it's a show,
Shelley Luther or the rest of us, what are we going to do to get out of this?
Yeah. Well, first off,
let me just say that Shelly Luther is a true American hero and every American
should believe that regardless of their political persuasion, I mean,
the woman wants to put food on her kid's table. It's a beautiful thing.
I'm here in California. I live in Los Angeles,
so I have a progressive governor and Gavin Newsome.
I've got a progressive mayor and Eric [inaudible],
who's literally telling me to go out and snitch on my neighbors and maybe I'm
going to get a reward. Gavin Newsome, of course, who's the governor.
He was the one that was the mayor of San Francisco.
And he basically ruined that city. And you know, they're,
they're telling us that we can't go to the beach. Well, here in,
so Cal it's about 85 and perfect today.
And I did get a little color in my backyard, but it's like, how about you?
Tell us something mature.
Tell us we have to go to the beach at half capacity and maybe have a car with a
space between another car. And you can only go in group support,
give us something that will make us feel like mature adults as you're supposed
to do as government officials.
Don't just say you can't go to the beach just because we say it as if,
as if what they say is true, just because they worded it.
And I think that's the problem with progressive. Generally.
They think that because they say something it's inherently true.
Well, you know, what's amazing about New York.
We just found out this week that some incredible number of people who were
staying at home, sheltering it at home. It's like 66%.
It may be even higher than that are coming up with a Corona virus.
So stay at home, you get the virus, at least let them get a tan, you know,
a little vitamin D would help them out. Don't you think.
A little vitamin D would help them out and I'll tell you this. Look, my family,
I, I come from New York. I was born in Brooklyn. I grew up in long Island.
I lived in Manhattan. Most of my life. Most of my family lives in New York,
my sister and her family. You know, the weather is good.
I thought we had a beach. Now we don't have it.
I'm not sure what I'm doing here, Texas is looking pretty good these days,
but I will tell you this, my, my sister and her family,
and two kids just moved out of New York city this week because people people
want to be free. Your intro is exactly right. Americans love Liberty,
love freedom. And by the way, we're willing to take a little risk to be free.
Nobody's saying,
just get out there and do whatever you want and crowd everything people are
saying, Hey, we got to get back to our lives. We're not hamsters in a cage.
And you got,
let us take a little risk so we can decide what the threshold is for
our lives, as opposed to just be getting it as an edict, uh, you know,
from somebody up in Sacramento in my case. Yeah.
Well, and the shame of it all is, you know, we've all been,
we've all been trained to wash our hands and keep our hands away from our face
that, um, you know, you would think they would figure, well,
they've got some of it, right. You know, maybe we can let them out a little bit.
But anyway, Dave Rubin,
I want to congratulate you on knitting the New York times bestsellers list.
Don't burn this book and we look forward to having you on again.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlists, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.